welcome to the city of denver colorado
the rockies now eat two the giants are
five at seven this is game three of a
four game set
infield in with a man at third in less
than two outs charlie blackmon the
hitter
first pitch swinging line drive base hit
come on down david dahl
pretty easy game huh
you reach out in there you go to second
on a wild pitch you take third on a fly
ball to center field then the third
hitter drives you in that is 12 rbis now
for charlotte
one out hilliard 90 feet away as dahl
comes up
this ball is lifted to deep right field
this will get the job done
dickerson makes the catch
hilliard scores easily two to nothing
colorado
[Applause]
so here's belt now belt's got really
good lifetime numbers against grace so
he might be the right guy in this
spot
belt it's a high drive to right
blackman bag or make that tapia
out of here
and the giants take the lead
now you were talking about the ownage
that belt has against john gray
and this is two strike thunder here and
that is the brand of belt happy zone
look at the slider not a whole lot of a
bite to it
hangs out there middle end right at the
knee and that is where he likes it
3-2 giants lead the rockies here's nolan
crawford's got it
that might be as high as he could go
right there somehow it looked like
aronado knew crawford was going to catch
it let's take a look at crawford going
up
and he's got some hops
how much of the glove does he use every
bit of it
two outs and here's
brandon bell
he hits another one high and deep to
right
this one's going to go over the head of
dahl
and belt is going to jog into second
base with a double
well take a look at the pitch they
wanted to go inside and leaks out over
the plate and he just
scolds it
to seamer
[Music]
barrels it up finds a gap
and with two outs puts them south and
scoring position
[Applause]
so here's
flores
lines this one in a base hit
coming into score will be belt and it's
four to two
so wilmer flora is not waiting around
jumping on the first fastball he could
get first pitch challenge two seed
fastball bang
two-run lead
here's nolan aronado to face watson
high fly ball deep left field make it
three games in a row rockies within a
run here comes nolan
now home run again for nolan arenado is
third of the year and the rockies are
back within four to three
4-3 giants bottom of the eighth
tyler rogers is the new pitcher
[Music]
and a strike
foul back it's now nothing in two
got him they saved that fastball for a
two-strike surprise prior to that he
kind of
flipped little breaking balls in there
the high 70s and here he zips him at 84.
and one of the real quick bats on this
team
just has 84 blowing right by him
hit to left
this should end the inning
and it does
nice job by rogers after the single by
walters
carlos estabaz is going to throw the top
of the ninth try to keep the rockies
within a run
flores hits it in the air to left field
coming on hard as hillard slides and
made the catch
sam hilliard with a wonderful play
sprawled in left field comes up with it
that's the speed that certainly helped
him it looked like this ball was going
to carry more than it did hilliard of
course playing deep as most outfielders
do got a good jump timed it perfectly
dropped down to a knee and reached out
to his right with that glove on his
right hand as a left-handed thrower
trevor gott's gonna stand in and he's
going to try to nail down these last
three outs
pop them up
this is
slater in right field one out
and that'll bring up
daniel murphy
lifted to left
two down
here's the pitch
and he struck him out fastball right on
the outside corner mid thigh
and hamson trying to fight it off
couldn't do it and the ball game is over
the giants come from behind and beat the
rockies 4-3
so the giants snapped their three-game
losing streak they win a game in
colorado which is always difficult to do
and this was a really really nice ball
game pitched by webb and then the
bullpen did a good job